we're asked to compare 156 point three
seven eight to 156 point three four
eight so I assume that they are trying
to they're asking us which of these is
greater and so let's rewrite these
numbers 156 point three seven eight and
we want to compare that to one hundred
and fifty six point three four eight and
it might already be obvious to you which
of these is greater but I'll work
through it step by step just in case
it's not so let's first go to the
hundreds place and you could view this
as to some degree the most significant
place because this is where you have the
largest you know the one in the hundreds
place represents a lot more than a one
in the tens place or one in the six is
place a one in a hundreds place
represents 100 it's this many hundreds
but we have the same number of hundreds
in both situations we have one hundred
and we have one hundred let's go to the
tens place we have five tens here which
is fifty and we have 50 right over here
so so far so they're there they're equal
so far if you just look at the hundreds
in the tens place let's go to the ones
place we have a 6 here in the ones place
six ones which is really just six and
you also have six ones so so far they're
equal again let's go to the tenths place
three tenths three tenths let's go to
the hundredths place so we're going into
smaller and smaller places so then you
have the seven hundredths we have seven
hundred now we have four hundredths here
so this has less hundredths than this
does over here and if we go to the
thousands place these are equal but it
doesn't matter even if these were
unequal it doesn't matter even if this
part was this one was larger than this
one because in the more significant
place this number was larger than this
number so seven is greater than four we
have seven seven hundredths here we have
four hundredths here so we get this
number is greater than this number down
here or 156 point three seven eight is
greater than 150 six point three four
eight and in particular it's because of
the hundredths place